one Florida Democrat County Commissioner
who happens to be a black man is
agreeing with santus he says this is
Leon County Commissioner Bill Proctor
says I think it's trash there's grave
concern about the tone and the tenor of
leadership's voice from the highest
spaces in our state being hostile to the
teaching of African-American history
frankly I'm against the college board's
curriculum I think it's trash it's not
African-American history it is ideology
I've taught African-American history
I've structured syllabuses for
African-American history I am
African-American history and talking
about queer and feminism and all of that
for the struggle for freedom and
equality and justice of black history
has nothing to do with queerness and
feminist thought at all totally agree
he's obviously right and it shows you
what the Democrats are counting on what
the libs are counting on here is that
they can call anything they want black
they can call anything they want you
know a women's issue they can they can
they can call any crazy thing they want
a civil rights issue and then they will
divide People based on race and sex